Speaker 1: All right, today I have, for your
consideration, maybe the new most dishonest
Fox News graphic of all time.
Now I'm referring there's there's a back story
here.
Couple of months ago, I told you about a different
graphic, which at the time I thought might
be the most dishonest Fox News graphic of
all time.
And it was a graphic just meant to make Joe
Biden look bad.
And it was about the American workforce and
the graphic that Fox News put up.
Compared the Trump workforce at its peak to
the Biden workforce in October, and it showed
that there were three million fewer people
in the workforce under Joe Biden in October
than under Trump at the peak.
Now, when you looked at the graphic, you could
immediately see it was an extraordinarily
deceptive cherry picking of data.
And you could see that they were cherry picking
the dates showing Trump in December of 2019.
But then Biden in October of 2021 with no
real rhyme or reason.
It ignores the reality of the pandemic.
It includes the reality that you can deceive
very easily with labor force participation
because with a growing population, at most
times in history, the U.S. has had more people
working than ever before and more people not
working than ever before.
Everything about it was extraordinarily deceptive.
But now I have a new graphic that might actually
be even more dishonest and deceptive on the
Dan Bongino Fox show, where Bongino might
have just been a guest.
I don't know if he was the host here.
They put up a graphic called Top Ten Most
Unhealthy U.S. cities, and the whole point
of the segment is to say Democrats say they're
going to fix problems, but they actually create
problems.
Look at all of these democratic cities and
how unhealthy they are, and you look at the
map and they say, Oh, Portland.
Maine is one of the most unhealthy cities
in the U.S. and right away you might be thinking,
Wait, what?
Portland, Maine?
Why is Portland an unhealthy city?
Seattle, Washington, Portland Port, Portland,
Oregon, that is San Francisco, Honolulu Wait,
isn't a Hawaii super healthy.
Why is handle?
So it looked like a weird graphic, and they
cite a source and the source is wallet hub.
So maybe you think wallet hub is reliable?
Maybe you don't.
It doesn't matter.
But right away, we should be asking, is this
actually what the Wallet Hub article says?
And if you go to the story on Wallet Hub,
which we are linking to, you see that their
map is actually the healthiest cities, not
the least healthy cities.
The healthiest cities that are identified
are the ones that are on the map.
Fox News says they're unhealthy San Francisco,
Seattle, Washington, Portland, Oregon, San
Diego, California, Honolulu, D.C., Austin,
Irvine, Portland.
So you immediately notice, first of all, they
list Irving, Texas when it's actually Irvine,
California, on the map.
And these are the healthiest cities, not the
least healthy if you actually look at the
unhealthiest U.S. cities, according to this
analysis, they are Brownsville, Texas, Laredo,
Texas, Gulfport, Mississippi, Shreveport,
Louisiana, Memphis, Tennessee, Montgomery,
Alabama, Fort Smith, Arkansas, Jackson, Mississippi.
Not exactly liberal cities.
If you look at the most obese cities in America,
which is a factor in health, McAllen, Texas
is the most obesity in the country.
Memphis, Baton Rouge, Little Rock, Shreveport,
Birmingham, Jackson Mobil, Lafayette.
It is truly pathetic.
And this is where I came up with this acronym
caps.
Cap stands for critically analyze primary
sources.
So when you're presented with a graphic like
this and it says top 10 most unhealthy U.S.
cities.
Your first question should be Is this a primary
source?
And of course, it's not the primary source.
Here is WalletHub, so your first step should
be to go and look at WalletHub.
When you look at wallet hub.
If you identify it as the primary source,
then you would say, OK, now let me critically
analyze this.
Well, what did WalletHub do while it?
Hub looked at the 180 most populated U.S.
cities.
They looked at 44 indicators of health, and
these are what they are.
And then you can actually say to yourself,
is this the right analysis?
Is the analysis done correctly?
What's being excluded?
What's being included?
But most importantly, does the data match
what Fox is giving us?
And the answer is, of course it doesn't.
Of course it does.
It's the opposite with the additional typo
where they put Irving, Texas, on the map instead
of Irvine, California.
An absolute and total humiliation.
I would argue the most humiliating graph or
chart that I've ever seen on Fox News.
If you have a counterpoint, if you have one
you think is more embarrassing or humiliating.
Let me know.
I would love to hear it.
And by the way, a couple of different Dan
Bongino stories one.
He's been kicked off of YouTube for spreading
COVID disinformation.
And number two, they actually the Bongino
people reached out to me a couple of weeks
ago, inviting me on to talk about some kind
of book band thing that I hadn't heard about
on a Friday night.
I wasn't available.
Should I appear on that show if they invite
me again?
I'd be interested in hearing from you.
I don't know that they will because I turned
him down.
But if they invite me again, should I appear
with Dan Bongino?
Let me know info at David Pakman dot com.